[Applaus]
[Musik]
wohl seit ihrem anbeginn versucht die
menscheit herauszufinden woher sie kommt
die alles um sie herum entstanden ist wo
und wie sie sich immer weiter in
unbekannte sphären und gebiete
ausbreiten kann und sie hat es immer
geschafft ihre grenzen noch weiter
auszudehnen auch dorthin wo sie zunächst
auf eine sehr lebensfeindliche umgebung
kamen diese kreis bildet zurzeit immer
noch das welt eine der letzten noch
nicht vollständig eroberten domänen seit
gut sechs jahrzehnten versucht man nun
den weltraum für menschen zugänglicher
und vertrauter zu machen und die
grundlegende frage dabei lautet warum
eigentlich den großen sprung in den
weltraum warten die menschen in den
späten 50er jahren als die vereinigten
staaten und die sowjetunion ein langes
und hartes wettrennen darum gegangen wer
den weltraum als erster erobert die
motivation war klar es geht eigentlich
gar nicht um das geld sondern um eine
kräftemessen zwischen zwei supermächten
wer ist der tollste schnellste und
klügste das weltall war nur ein
spielfeld und im grunde austauschbar
[Musik]
eine geschichte der wir sie alle nur zu
gut kennen alphamännchen braucht nun mal
ihren schwanzvergleich nun
interessanterweise trug dieser
wettbewerb aber in erheblichem maße zur
wissenschaftlichen und technologischen
entwicklungen im allgemeinen bei im
grunde genommen mussten diese beiden
großmächte so viel geld und so viel
ressourcen für ihren wettlauf investiert
dass dieser neben der sagen wir
moralischen überlegenheit als erster den
besseren erobert zu haben
auch große wissenschaftliche
technologische und militärische
fortschritte brachte genau militärische
glaubt nicht eine sekunde lang daran
dass das wettrennen weltraum vor allem
der wissenschaft und dem wohl der
menschheit dienen sollte also gar nicht
tatsache ist dass sich mit dem ende des
kalten krieges und dem fall der
sowjetunion die dinge zu ändern begannen
dem ehemaligen story staaten ging das
geld aus und die vereinigten staaten
begann allmählich immer weniger ihre
staatsbudget ist in die raumfahrt zu
investieren seit 1991 mehr als 50
prozent
als klar war wer den längsten hatte und
es somit keinen möglichen wettbewerb
begann die regierungen insbesondere die
usa das interesse am weltraum zu
verlieren der wettlauf um die
vorherrschaft kehrte auf die erde zurück
und das eben den weg fährt immer
stärkeres engagement privater
unternehmen genau private unternehmen
gegenwärtig in vittel mehr als ein
dutzend privatunternehmen raketen um
verschiedene dinge ist also das alles
hat lippen vorräte für die
internationale raumstation und sogar
passagiere
wahrscheinlich hast du schon von spacex
virgin galactic bei origin anderem
gehört und das wirft einige fragen auf
entsteht da ein riesiger neuer markt der
weltraum eroberung wird die zukunft der
menschheit im weltall wirklich im
privaten sektor entschieden wenn ja was
wird dann mit den regierungsbehörden
geschehen werden sie in der lage sein an
der seite der privaten unternehmen zu
koexistieren
was sich diese fragen interessieren dann
höchst gut zu denen wir werden ihre
beantwortung nachgehen
[Musik]
spielerwechsel
wir vorhin gesehen haben waren an der
eroberung des weltalls im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert im wesentlichen zwei
traktoren beteiligten vereinigten
staaten um die sowjetunion stellten sich
der herausforderung indem sie riesige
geldsummen investierten allein für das
apollo programm fertig vereinigten
staaten zu heutigen preisen mehr als 150
milliarden dollar ausgegeben das sind
150 milliarden dollar für ein programm
das mehr als 400.000 menschen
beschäftigte und das zum goldstandard
für das amerikanische weltraumprogramm
werden zu dieser zeit war der luft und
raumfahrtsektor so wichtig dass die
us-regierung sehr schnell die absolute
kontrolle über alle in ihrem
hoheitsbereich standen raumfahrtprojekt
übernahm im jahr 1967 einigten sich die
vereinigten staaten die sowjetunion und
das vereinigte königreich auf den
weltraum vertrag einen vertrag der unter
anderem die verantwortung der
regierungen für alle aktivitäten
nichtstaatlicher raumfahrt einrichtungen
festlegte das heißt dass jedes
unternehmen oder jede andere private
luft und raumfahrt organisation der
regierung ihres landes unterstellt war
in der praxis bedeute dies dass jedes
privatwirtschaftliche projekt vom
herkunftsland des unternehmens
ausdrücklich genehmigt werden musste und
nicht nur das ja der staat letztendlich
für das handeln des unternehmens
verantwortlich war lag die ausrichtung
jedes projektes letztendlich in den
händen von politikern und beamten
am ende waren es die regierungen die den
laufenden betrieb der luft und
raumfahrtunternehmen genehmigten die
jetzt haltet euch fest dieser vertrag
ist bis heute in kraft doch aufgrund der
tatsache dass der wettlauf ins weltall
internationale angelegenheiten an fahrt
verloren hat wurde die anwendung des
vertrags immer weniger und weniger
strikt ausgelegt und dann dessen konnte
der private raum sektor immer mehr
freiheiten gewinnen dieses soll ein
neuer bedeutung denn seit ein paar
jahren kommt der wettlauf ins weltall
wieder ins rollen und steht vor einer
neuen goldenen ära und dies geschieht
nicht rein zufällig sondern hat einen
ausschlaggebenden grund der abbau von
eintrittsbarrieren okay lasst mich das
etwas genauer erklären
wir alle haben so war es schon im
kleineren maßstab erlebt technologie
wird in den letzten jahrzehnten immer
billiger und die fähigkeiten unserer
geräte telefone oder autos haben einen
exponentiellen sprung vollführt weil das
hat sich auch auf den luft- und
raumfahrtbereich ausgedrückt und alles
viel viel zugänglicher gemacht denkt man
einen moment darüber nach die
rechenleistung eines supercomputers aus
den neunziger jahren zu dem nordiren und
riesige multinationale konzerne zugriff
hatten nachdem sie millionen für dieses
privileg bezahlen mussten hat heute
jedes bessere smartphone und
rechenleistung ist nicht nur einer von
vielen bausteinen die sprungkraft besser
und erschwinglicher geworden sind dies
erklärt warum immer mehr auch kleinere
länder nun ihre eigenen
raumfahrtprogramme und agenturen haben
können
ja wir sprechen nicht nur von
supermächten wie china die sich dem
neuen weltraum rennen anschließend in
dem sie durch die eingangstür stürmen
sondern auch von viel weniger mächtigen
ländern wie zum beispiel luxemburg oder
gar ja das ist richtig so agrana hat
eine weltraumbehörde aber die wirkliche
erschütterung in diesen neuen rennen ist
das nicht mehr die regierungen an den
fenstern sondern private unternehmen und
das ist ein wahrer paradigmenwechsel
jetzt da mehr regierungen vor allem neue
unternehmen beteiligt sind stellt sich
die frage stehe kurz vor einem noch
aufregenderen weltraum rennen als damals
israelisches unternehmen schickt die
weltweit erste privat finanzierte
mission zum mond
schon drei jahren 2 erfolg beim zweiten
versuch indiens eine mond mission zu
starken lauf hat unternehmen wie spacex
sind in der lage eine rakete für
schlappe 57 millionen dollar in die
unteren erdumlaufbahn zu schießen das
macht viel klingen aber wenn man es in
den fast 500 millionen dollar vergleicht
die der start des space shuttles
gekostet hat klingt es wie ein
schnäppchen
und es ist genau diese verbesserte
effizienz bei den kosten und ressourcen
der privaten luft und raumfahrtindustrie
dazu geführt hat dass die regierung
arbeit selbst aufgeben und stattdessen
zu kunden werden die regierungen sind
jetzt kunst und von privaten und luft
und raumfahrtunternehmen die autonom
arbeiten natürlich bedienten sich
öffentliche einrichtungen die nasa von
anfang an träger das zulieferer genauso
wie es armee und luftwaffe
aber es ist ein gewaltiger unterschied
ob ein externer liefert ein einzelnes
spezielles dinge im auftrag einer
staatlichen raumfahrtbehörde herstellt
oder die verantwortung für ein
eigenständiges raketenprogramm
übertragen bekommt anders ausgedrückt es
ist der gleiche unterschied wie wenn ein
rüstungsunternehmen der armee panzer
liefert oder dieses unternehmen die
ganze panzerarmee selbst aufbauen
besitzen und das kommando darüber führen
würde im ersten fall tritt die regierung
an entscheidung in zweiter ist es das
unternehmens selbst dass die initiative
ergreift die entscheidung selbst
entscheidet wofür wie wann und wie viel
geld ausgegeben wird nun und das ist
genau das was beim jetzigen wettlauf ins
weltall vorsichtig steuern wir also auf
eine vollkommene privatisierung der
raumfahrt zu schauen das ist erst mal
aus der nähe
[Musik]
ein gut getimter gucken
für die usa ist es nicht mehr sinnvoll
jeden einzelnen bereich des luft- und
raumfahrtsektor center das staatliche
monopol zu stellen
es macht dich nur keinen sinn es ist
sogar kontraproduktiv
unter dem neuen paradigma während die
regierungsbehörden ihre ressourcen auf
die wissenschaftliche grundlage
forschung konzentrieren wie zum beispiel
die untersuchungen der mondoberfläche
dass frieden das sterne oder der am
weitesten entfernten planeten der
zwischenzeit werden sich private
unternehmen mit der angewandten
forschung und technik befassen das heißt
mit dem angebot konkreter produkte und
dienstleistungen wie zb der
standardisierten beförderung in den
orbit mit wiederverwendbaren raketen und
satelliten der herstellung von
satelliten und in geringerem maße auch
mit dem vielgepriesenen
weltraumtourismus diese koexistenz und
arbeitsteilung und die zusammenarbeit
zwischen öffentlichen stellen
unternehmen könnte uns die bisher besten
jahre der weltraumforschung bescheren
aber lasst uns nur zur eigentlichen
schlüsselfrage kommen warum ist es
privaten unternehmen gelungen in bezug
auf kosteneffizienz und innovation so
viel besser abzuschneiden als typische
staatliche raumfahrtbehörden ohne sich
erkennen die liefern euch die antwort
bereits wettbewerb denn ein markt in dem
wettbewerb herrscht erfüllt drei
funktionen besonders gut erstens
verteilung zweitens schaffung von
anreizen das heißt die förderung von
technischen fortschritt und innovation
und drittens steuerung das heißt ein
angebot entsprechend dem bedarf und den
nachfrage präferenzen somit eine lenkung
der produktionsfaktoren in ihrer
effizienteste verwendet
ein wettbewerbsorientierte markt schafft
also eine optimale ressourcenallokation
wenn in diesem geht es ganz einfach
darum dinge zu schaffen die zu einem
vernünftigen preis funktionieren und mit
ihnen geld zu verdienen geld das
übrigens in der regel von den
regierungsbehörden selbst kommt zwischen
den jahren 2000 2018 haben verschiedene
öffentliche einrichtungen in den
vereinigten staaten die die nasa und die
luft war 5 7,2 milliarden dollar
in 67 luft und raumfahrtunternehmen
investiert sollen all diesen geldern
begeben 93 prozent an unternehmen die
sich auf raketenstart spezialisiert
haben unternehmen wie spacex und so
erzielte jeder wird öffentlichen
einrichtungen investiert dollar
bessere ergebnisse selbst wenn also
beispielsweise diskutieren a sagte solis
hat sich ihre ausgaben effizienz
deutlich erhöht morgen vor dem bug elon
musk behauptet die neue rakete space
exporte wie würde die konkurrenz auf der
kostenseite zerstören cnbc
deshalb investiert die nasa geld in
unternehmen wie spacex praktisch seit
ihrer gründung schaut während des ersten
jahrzehnts seiner existenz hat asics
eine milliarde dollar ausgegeben
ungefähr die hälfte dieses geldes stammt
aus regierungsaufträgen der nasa mit
anderen worten die nasa finanzierte
einen großen teil des wachstums von
spacex und die wahrheit ist dass diese
strategie für beide seiten gut
funktioniert hat die entwicklungen von
spacex haben zum beispiellosen und
erheblichen kosteneinsparungen für die
nasa geführt seit 1981 sind die kosten
pro kilo das in die untere eck
umlaufbahn geschickt wird von mehr als
85.000 dollar beim space shuttle auch
weniger als 2.000 dollar
bei der fahrt nein von spacex gefallen
das ist eine kostensenkung von fast 99
prozent und das ist erst der anfang denn
schon bald versprechen andere ketten wie
die falcon heavy die kosten pro ins all
geschossen kilogramm unter 1000 dollar
marke zu drücken und viele von euch
beschäftigt an dieser stelle sich die
frage aber mark was ist mit europa du
sprichst die ganze zeit nur über die usa
was aber tut sich europa nun europa hat
arianespace das europäische
raumfahrtunternehmen dass die meisten
esa stars durchführt und die europäische
weltraumorganisation doch es gibt einige
unterschiede
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und europa turnier nun lost in space
wenn ich dir sagen würde dass vor nicht
allzu langer zeit arianespace weltweit
führend war bei kommerziellen
raketenstart
was wirst du denn nun ich benutze die
vergangenheitsform weil wie du diese
grafiken nehmen kannst europa ab 2013
und auf grund des erfolgs von spacex
seine dominierende position bei der zahl
der kommerziellen raketenstarts
zugunsten der vereinigten staaten
verloren hat nun stelle sich die frage
warum ist ein unternehmen die
arianespace das fast 20 prozent des
jahresbudgets der esa von rund sechs
milliarden dollar in anspruch nimmt
unfähig mit neu gegründeten unternehmen
wie spacex zu konkurrieren warum haben
die usa in dieser branche alle hinter
sich gelassen wie du sehen kannst wurde
arianespace 1980 gegründet und mit dem
veralteten und teure space hat mit der
usa zu konkurrieren in den 90er jahren
gelangen ist der ariane-5-rakete die
stadt kosten auf 175 millionen dollar zu
senken
verglichen mit den mehr als 450 belegung
dollar die der staat ist bei shuttle
kostete ein schnäppchen aber zusätzlich
zu ihren für die damalige zeit
beeindruckend niedrige kosten wurde die
ariane-5 auch zur zuverlässigsten rakete
sie ist ja nur zwei absolute fehlschläge
bei mehr als 100 stars darunter ein sehr
bekannter programmierfehler
alles schien also darauf hinzudeuten
dass europa in den kommenden jahrzehnten
eine führende position einnehmen würde
und tatsächlich war diese mehrere jahre
das heißt bis 2013 der fall
aber wir alle wissen der ärgste feind
des guten ist das bessere und das blatt
wendete sich schnell als plötzlich das
175 millionen dollar teure preisschild
für den start der ariane 5
im vergleich zu den etwa 60 millionen
dollar der vaart nein von spex nicht
mehr ganz so günstig erschienen und
genau da liegt das problem der
europäischen luft- und
raumfahrtindustrie
sie konnte oder wollte sich nicht neu
erfinden kaufen sie ein matthäus weil er
billig ist stefano wie angie direktor
der abteilung entwicklung von
trägerraketen der esa
das gilt nicht nach der besten strategie
um auf einen markt zu konkurrieren auch
den neue amerikanischer start ups mit
niedrigen preisen auf den plan treten
oder jedenfalls versuchen sie nun mit
der entwicklung der areale 6n die
fußstapfen der nordamerikanischen
konkurrenz zu treten deren start kosten
sollen rund 95 millionen dollar betrage
2021 soll es losgehen
das ist das ergebnis von wettbewerb
immer mehr agenturen unternehmen und
fachleute konkurrieren darum im luft und
der sektor fuß zu fassen und wenn uns
die erfahrung etwas gelehrt habe dann
ist es dass vor allem gesunder
wettbewerb zu neuen errungenschaft
geführt im raumfahrtsektor der zunehmend
von privaten unternehmen dominiert wird
hat dies auf jeden fall gut getan so
oder die springende frage die sich heute
hinterlassen lautet können diese
unternehmen mehr als nur effizienz
werden unternehmen wie spacex virgin
galactic oder blue origin in der lage
sein den wettlauf ins weltall auf ein
neues niveau zu heben schreibt uns eure
meinung und erkenntnisse darüber bittet
in den kommentarbereich unter dieses
video
denn wie immer freuen wir uns auf eure
angeregte diskussion und wisst ihr dass
wir jede woche neue informative videos
für euch vorbereitet und veröffentliche
wenn ihr also keines dieser aktuellen
updates verpassen wollt abonniert wird
der politik und drückt danach auch auf
die klingel taste um keines davon zu
verpassen
wenn euch dieses video etwas gebracht
hat dann gibt es auch einen daumen hoch
teilt dieses video mit euren freunden
und macht es gut bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]